j'ai l'impression mike horn vous un peu
chine est impossible impossible
il n'y a pas de libido il ya aucun
chinage possible pendant quatre jours ya
aucune hygiène a pratiquement pas non
nous dit on n'a même pas besoin de ça en
fait d'entraînement on ressent pas
l'envié oui vous devriez aller là bas
vous jour michel avec shane cough elle
ne servirait pas à grand-chose - ben oui
moi ça qui m'arrête à l'ordre à l'état
sauvage
on vous a vu il ya rien regardez où vous
avez fait une petite vidéo un petit peu
c'est ça que c'est un petit peu love
love avec iphone regarde
[Musique]
battez-vous comme ça
non
c'est comme un petit gars
m
mais pour de vrai cette nuit j'ai choisi
vasic
je suis candidate